you're watching the GameSpot stage
brought to you by airheads hi folks and
welcome back to game Sports coverage of
e3 2016 great to have you back it's our
final game of the show we've been here
for 12 years looking at all the games
that have been shown games we knew about
games we did not know about and this is
one we did not know about it all Ron and
Eric from Sony Bend studios gone you
guys used to make a game called Syphon
Filter that we did really popular series
games good fun and you've obviously been
working with Sony and a bunch of other
things but in the meantime you've been
working on this game which surprised us
all at the conference days gone
congratulations first of all I'm keeping
it a secret
thank you very much and for working on
this game and there were some rumors
like floating around months and months
months ago I bet that you guys may be
working on some sort of zombie biker
right thing and turns out there might be
relatively close tell us about days gone
so days gone is an open-world adventure
game set in the beautiful high desert
the Pacific Northwest and if you guys
didn't know that's our Studios backyard
all right yeah so it's up in Seattle or
it's all under it's kind of central
organ ok yeah the Northwest goes all the
way through Seattle good so and yeah so
you take control of Deacon st. John
which is a drifter a bounty hunter and
I'm sure you can tell by the color in
his back that he's a was an emcee of a
motorcycle gang and yeah he basically
uses his appetite for violence and
mayhem to survive out in this dangerous
world right it's two years it's set two
years after a global pandemic has wiped
out most of the population and turned
millions into these feral creatures that
we call freaker's right I'm something
like really strong like Sons of Anarchy
vibes from this I mean obviously you
take bikers yes
modern day at least you think sons of
anarchy right what other inspirations
did you have there's a we take
inspiration from all kinds of things
from media from music to pretty much
everything it's this game is kind of a
culmination of everything that our group
loves all right well into one thing and
you know it's extremely exciting for us
because this is as you
saying because our first original IP in
a while yeah yeah since second holder in
the 1990s right right yeah yeah which is
crazy and yeah it's just extremely
exciting for us to do this you know you
pretty much want to get one chance and
and this is what we write you want to
show so let's talk about the the very
impressive demo that you guys showed in
fact we got two bites at the cherry we
saw it earlier in the conference and
then they finished on it as well yeah
and which was wonderful with the whole
office here which is sort of like glued
to the screens what enjoying this one
and how would escalate it was quite
something else and so it's great to he
guys talking about this being an open
world experience was one of the things
about this this demo was that it it it's
very well produced obviously for the
purpose of showing what the game is but
it also felt like it might have been a
little kind of you were honest like it
was like a linear sort of progression
that was happening here so talk about
sort of like what you were trying to do
with this to explain to gamers what the
game was so that actually was one of the
missions in the game that takes place
later on and you know you're you're
going in there for something can't talk
about it yet yeah you have a goal and
you do have an objective for that
mission and your goal is to clear out
the entire horde and depending on how
you approach it the different weapons
the upgrades the ammo that you take it
can play out completely different right
you saw Deacon get a oil filter for his
pistol yeah so he was trying to attempt
to go into that situation stuff like but
things things didn't work out in his
favor excellence I'm just talking about
some of the technology involved here as
well like you're talking like massive
amounts of zombies moving route moving
very very fast as well and presumably
this is quite a difficult feat to
achieve oh absolutely
um we have a yeah an evil genius locked
away right yeah working on this for us
you know we've taken our we're using a
pretty heavily modified version of the
Unreal all right now for engine which
helped our studio you know hit the
ground running baby win and yeah it's
it's a very impressive feat and that's
why we wanted to show that but here's
the thing it's only a very very small
snippet of of our game the whole game is
not that there are games the game is
about much much more and we can't wait
to you know unveil way more in the
future yeah I mean it's incredibly
impressive especially when you see the
Horde moving even just now on three we
could see all of the Freak is moving
the animations look really slick look
really solid I mean hopefully this is
gonna make like a ps4 like collapse and
die in a puff of smoke right right been
optimized oh yeah yeah I know it's it's
heavily optimized running on ps4 and the
really cool thing with the Horde is you
know each and every one of those guys
has their own behavior in right every
one of them is making their own
decisions and going after the player but
at the same time they're thinking as one
and you know you see in the demo that
the players constantly trying to
distance himself or or knock things over
to kind of make a gap yeah just create a
couple yards
yeah extra and you know that's that's
super important to being able to take on
the Horde because just trying to run
away from them they're gonna take you
out so I guess like you know you're
obviously like showing off this little
snippet and I'm sure you're keeping a
lot of stuff private for later on during
the course of its development but sort
of like like generally what do you do is
there a lot of like exploration in this
game is there is it mostly gun combat is
it you know lots of traversal I mean
there's so many things you think about
life at the Pacific Northwest it's all
about sort of like nature and exploring
and things like that is there an element
of that happening here oh absolutely
so the one thing that we you know we
really haven't gone too much little bit
into the trailer but that we showed at
the beginning of this conference we have
a living world it's a living ecosystem
and this is again you know 2 years after
this pandemic right so the survivors
it's it again it's a dangerous world and
people that have survived are desperate
and just for people do what they need to
do to survive and it's there's a living
as I was saying the living cycle there's
a day and night cycle there's a being in
the Pacific Northwest there's very
extreme weather right yeah of course it
one minute it could be a hundred degrees
in the next minute it could be snowing
um all of that affects the world right
and you know these these particular
these freaker's are they're living
they're not they're not the undead right
living so in a kind of a weird way
they're doing the same thing that you're
trying to do is which is survive right
yeah yeah yeah yeah ok I would say in
the press comment of Izzy this is the
one path that Deacon's taken can you
take multiple paths and when working
where you can see freak is like break
through the windows your to grab a him
at a scripted events or is it can it be
randomized
it's completely randomized so these well
when I say randomized they have
behaviors and they do they do specific
things so we we pride ourselves with
this being an open world that we give
you the freedom to play the game how you
want to play if you want to be the guy
that is stealthy sure you can you can do
this if you want to be the guy that does
gun blazing you can do this and and you
know you're progressing you're deacon in
that direction you know there was a
little bit with the extended demo that
we showed a little bit more into into
this for instance you know deacons a
pretty smart guy he can take a lot of
the things in the field I kind of
MacGyver things together um for instance
there and we can make an airbag bombs
you could take an airbag from a car
right together with cellphone and a few
other things and then you can make these
bombs and you can place them and so if
you're the type of guy that likes to set
traps you can go and you can survey the
area first set up the traps and then
kind of lure the guys in so again yeah I
mean you can play the game however you
want and that's that's the beauty I
guess like it there's always you know
zombie is almost its own I know these
aren't zombies but like that this idea
of like hordes right is in and of itself
its own sort of like genre it's unlike
sub-genre of Mediate not just video
games as well and there's this sort of
like different scale where you have like
you've got you know our you know Daisy
maybe you're like this sort of like
survivalist elements on one end and
they've got something like you know Dead
Rising sitting on the other which is all
sort of like bombast and you know
creating ridiculous weaponry and stuff
like that and you know not to give you a
linear scale but like where do you guys
what type of experience you trying to
create you know how realistic do you
want to keep us without sort of also
limiting what players do or like was it
where was your sort of ethos like where
as you're lying there I mean it the game
is super realistic no and we've taken a
lot of inspiration from stuff that's out
there and like you know Deacon was part
of a motorcycle club and so we took a
lot of inspiration from that because you
know they're they're known for mayhem
and they're known for violence since
yeah like that but you know if you're in
there it's about Brotherhood it's about
family and stuff and that's the thing
that he holds on to you know he takes
the skills that he's learned as part of
this motorcycle gang out into the world
to try to survive but he's got that
Brotherhood and you know
he he wants to hold on to some of the
stuff of his past but he's looking
forward to the hope that might be on
there in surviving in this world
we've got bunches of questions coming
and I want to get get to as many of them
as I can
otto Moto's asking any survival elements
on to what extent have you know it's an
open-world game but obviously this
mission structures and stuff like that
you're talking about some elements of
crafting are you doing that with
survival as well absolutely the thing is
in this world again it's dangerous right
you're constantly out there trying to
survive it's not just you out there as
well
you know deacons a drifter he doesn't
stay in the same place at the same time
right so he's always going around and
you know in our trailer we kind of give
you a little glimpse into this where
there was a gate deacon walked up and
these guys were opening the gate yeah we
came in right so it kind of gives you an
idea that there are more survivors out
there and there's you're not just doing
again he's a bounty hunter so you're not
just doing things for just you surviving
em you're helping up others as well so
Deacon looks incredibly familiar really
all right all right yeah so what was the
process like working with him because
obviously he's a big Hollywood actor has
he been involved in the process from the
very beginning has he helped help form
the character Deacon anyway absolutely
um you know we working on our previous
project which was golden the best for
the PlayStation Vita yeah you know we
our studio has evolved in how we tell
story and how we show the story and he
has helped us dramatically with a we do
performance capture and you know we use
his face and we use everything so he is
deacon hmm no I saw him at e3 about
three three years ago right before I was
like why are you here
you guys presumably been working on this
for quite a long time that I mean it
looks like it looks like I'm quite a big
undertaking we've been working out for a
few years yeah yeah Atlee lots of
questions coming in about I know this
stuff tends to get super specific
especially when people are excited about
the game but I'm guessing he's a biker
do you have a bike
absolutely yeah there's there's a
motorcycle that you can see at the
beginning of the demo it's very key
deikun you know right it's his bike you
know a lot of other games have
disposable vehicles yeah like that and
and this is his motorcycle you know it's
it's something that you know as he's
been out in the world he's adapted
himself but he's also adapted his
motorcycle to take on the rugged terrain
of the Pacific Northwest and so it's
important to keep that nearby and you
sell with the hoard you know if things
had gone south he could have bailed and
you know gotten back to his bike right
taking off so it's important to keep
that nearby yeah a lot of questions
about different weapon or you could use
modifying that weaponry and stuff I
thought you going down that rabbit hole
as well we have a ton of weapons in the
game you know one of the interesting
thing is about being in the Pacific
Northwest they're all very much gun
yes I'm sure yeah and yeah it's very
very interesting off the land and
absolutely yeah so I mean again we with
ton of weapons and lots of variety in
our game good right but definitely to
announce plenty more in the months to
come
yeah how far away from like launch are
you guys like we're not yeah when t18
we're looking we're not really going
into that yeah yeah yeah we're we will
see you at e3 again perhaps fences will
again um what I was gonna ask is it
don't even two years since like this
global pandemic I mean what's the what's
the state of the world I mean typically
in like post pandemic games you get you
get it like 30 years later so it there's
already been time for a new world order
to kind of settle in I guess things are
still very volatile yes it's still in
the beginning of everything in our game
it's there are areas that have I mean
just without if you're if you don't
upkeep the roads
things happen right so there's a lot of
that in the game right so two years
actually can do a lot of damage to the
world especially with the harsh
environment like with the Pacific
Northwest like yeah the weather is crazy
you know we're constantly dealing with
potholes and stuff and you know you you
let the roads sit for too long and they
start falling apart so not only is the
environment you know off-road dangerous
but the roads are dangerous too because
you know you've got washed out freeways
and abandoned vehicles and stuff and
that's what makes the motorcycle so
important to this right is maneuvering
around the environment you've got
blocked roads all over the place but the
by
can fit through yep at game studios are
so often making video games in like
iconic locations that they then travel
to and sort of learn about it what's it
like making a game about basically a
fact or about like face - presumably you
quite enjoy being in or absolutely so
much fun and it's it's unique to us and
that's kind of the thing it's like we've
never seen any game set in anything like
that if I give ton of different areas
from you know the mountainous regions to
you know lust lush forests to you know
the whole area is built on this ancient
lava flow and you know we're being 4,000
feet and above right it's home to some
very interesting for instance they we
have these huge lava tube caves that you
can you know traverse Internet yeah it's
a very very interesting environment
that's for sure yeah is there like a
pride associated with that as well you
sort of like represent the places only
well as possible what a bit like I guess
even like the local cultures and stuff
like that because that's always you know
we we've got so many of these wonderful
worlds that are like they look so much
like their real-world counterparts but
then often times the sort of the actual
people who live there and the things
they talk about and the things that they
value are kind of misaligned it doesn't
really work out presumably you guys have
a pretty good you know insight into that
being resident yeah yeah there's there's
the cool thing about Oregon is there's a
lot of really small towns that are kind
of tourist trap kind of things right and
you'll see in the trailer there's a
there's a giant statue of you know guy
with the Paul Bunyan looking axe and
stuff and there's a lot of character to
the little towns that are in Oregon and
soon we've we've kind of taken a little
bit of that and put into the game
awesome are animals affected by the
pandemic I mean I'm interested in
thinking in terms of like food and
scavenging sure like tinned food would
still be okay but is there any scope for
other creatures not just freaking you
folks like hunting up there right yeah
we're not we're not going to too much
detail about that right now but in the
trailer you can see that there's wolves
and I saw some wolves in the the demo
and then there's some deer and a couple
shots so it's definitely a living world
there is an ecosystem there good stuff
at what's the we're almost done here in
a second but what's what's the mood like
it at Bend at the moment you guys have
obviously been busy for the past couple
of years have you been there for a long
time should you work on psyphon filters
and the earlier ones as well yeah I've
been with the team since Syphon Filter 2
and I actually moved
up to Bend I was from Foster City and
actually right and around second fold or
three okay and yeah so I've been with
the team designing since then and so
what's it feel like you two to have it
out there especially must be finally we
want to be how happy we are to talk
about it yeah yeah it's incredible like
I it's cool I started it in QA at Rice
video and you know now I'm getting to
design this game that we just showed and
you know it's this big huge game that's
getting all this in tension and I'm I'm
just blown away like it's it's really
cool you know I've been there 10 years
we did some of the Syphon Filter games I
worked on golden Abyss and and this is
just next level so we're super excited
absolutely it's not every day you get to
announce a new IP no not at all yeah our
entire studio is going crazy right now
right oh man seems like you put the work
in as well it's been a long a long time
since the feedback we've been getting
has been overwhelming mmm crazy yeah
it's good stuff I mean are you okay with
that because the other thing that
happens a lot at e3 is that you've got
like games like watchdogs in the
division or in Oman sky where then you
guess this like this over hype and this
over attention oh and you guys feeling
that a little better is it not at all
we're riding the wave right yeah that's
who enjoy it yeah awesome well thank you
both for coming in act for folks I mean
Oh obviously this is a ways away at this
stage at but for folks you want to keep
up to date on the project where should
they be following or looking you can
check out our twitter account at Ben
studio and then playstation vlog is
going to be posting stuff so awesomely
thank you so much gentlemen
yeah did you enjoy your III experience
laughs whatever you got to talk to
people about your game yeah without the
world excellent side looking forward to
seeing you hit probably again here next
year thank you good stuff I thank you
all so much for watching that was our
final game but we've got one more
section we're gonna get a bunch of the
GameSpot editors who have actually been
coming and playing games I like me and
Lucy to come on the stage and talk about
what their favorite game of the show has
been so far so stick around back in a
couple minutes